you notice this in mind you guys have a
haze anybody at work I still work in
this warehouse and we were we were a
bunch of [ __ ] maniacs and all day
long all we did was break balls I've
told you this [ __ ] before because we
were basically mentally smart enough to
work in a warehouse by the time you were
in third grade you know what I mean
supposed to be ten boxes according to
the packing list one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten there you go
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve sorry
Sesame Street flashback er um so we used
to [ __ ] around all the time and our
manager had no control over us you know
we didn't respect him we knew he wasn't
going to win fire he wasn't gonna fire
us he didn't have the goddamn heart and
at the end of the day we got a [ __ ]
job done so he decides that were the
problem is is that we're all too [ __ ]
young there's a level of immaturity out
there because we were all in our early
20s that we that he should hire he hired
this 38 year old guy
I actually remember his name but I'm not
gonna I don't name names on this [ __ ]
and Jesus Christ that [ __ ] guy's
almost 60
he was like 38 and that was 22 [ __ ]
years ago he's 60 what the [ __ ] so
anyways this guy drove a [ __ ] sky
blue Chevy Cavalier station wagon
four-door bare-bones factory [ __ ]
rims the car was like three years old he
had 8,000 miles on it alright and this
guy was a weirdo and he had these
[ __ ] glasses these black frame
glasses that nobody wore in the 80s so
we immediately started calling him woody
we be hey woody uh how many boxes we get
over there and this guy was just bizarre
and he come over why call me what are
you are you trying to bring me down so
you kept saying you're trying to bring
me down then I already tell this [ __ ]
story this sounds oddly familiar to me
so we would just [ __ ] with them we would
just be like okay at 4:31 today
everybody just start going woody woody
woody woody and that's way with dope he
would be picking orders down in the in
the warehouse area and
we would all be picking orders with them
and then out of nowhere we would just
suck old woody woody woody woody woody
woody woody woody woody at the top of
our [ __ ] lungs I know it's [ __ ] am
as sophomoric but it would fall and what
we wouldn't say it to him we would just
[ __ ] Meese it was really
passive-aggressive
because he already talked to management
about us calling him woody so it's like
don't we're not calling you woody
we're just going woody woody woody woody
woody look in your vicinity so he do the
same thing trying to bring me down you
try to bring me down so eventually we
haze this guy so much that he [ __ ]
quit right he and his little Chevy
Cavalier [ __ ] four-door sky-blue
bare-bones station wagon drove right out
in the back of my head I was like you
know what I got a bad feeling that
[ __ ] coming back right right
around the time when people first
started going postal so it wasn't enough
that we actually drove this guy out of
work one of the [ __ ] maniacs I worked
with somehow got the guy's home phone
number and the following week he still
didn't have a job and he picked up the
phone he's like hello and there was ten
of us standing around the phone and we
all go woody woody woody woody woody and
I always pictured him slamming the phone
down and then looking up like that dude
in a Clockwork Orange when he realizes
the dude who came and [ __ ] kicked the
[ __ ] out of him and raped his wife game
back um that's kind of an ugly story
isn't it you know but you know for as
much as people sit there and they talk
about this cyber bullying and all this
type of [ __ ] and how [ __ ] horrible it
is which it is obviously you know I
don't like how everybody tries to act
like they were a victim
what we weren't you a little bit of both
because I know I used to get bullied
Jesus Christ walking up the street
looking like [ __ ] that kid on the
family Griffith what the [ __ ] is that
they have Andy Griffith how did I come
up with the family Griffith yeah my
[ __ ] brain is mush yeah people you
immediately came walking up the street
my [ __ ] my hair was orange when I was
growing up I think I didn't get the [ __ ]
kicked out of me
you know but then you know I got a
little bit bit bigger I got a couple
more freckles I got some more confidence
and I just started picking on kids who
were younger than I was so now whenever
I see those goddamn stories I I just I
don't know I I see both sides of it I
just see like yeah you shouldn't have
[ __ ] done that but I don't judge the
bully cuz I did [ __ ] like that now
you guys didn't do [ __ ] like that yeah
go [ __ ] yourselves alright once you guys
do you know what that's the theme of
this whole podcast everybody go [ __ ]
themselves